okay so now let's get into the the bar
walk back as I'm calling it exactly as
I've been saying for a week now Donald
Trump's Attorney General William Bar is
now saying that his four-page summary of
the Moller report isn't actually a
summary of the full investigation it was
just as I told you some things that he
chose to say but last week I started
referring to what Barr published as a
supposed summary of moller summary of
the investigation as I told you in the
last story on today's show we now know
that the molar summary of the full
investigation is three to four hundred
pages long it's an investigation that
could have a million or more pages of
investigative data evidence testimony
and more documents it obviously became
untenable to maintain that these four
measly pages from William Barr could
respectably be called a summary of the
full investigation so what William bard
did it's really very clever he snuck
into a letter that he put out over this
weekend that his four-page letter last
weekend is not actually a summary of the
investigation and this has barely gotten
any attention but it's so important I
want to go through the documents in the
articles with you CNN Justice Department
correspondent Laura Jarrett published
this latest letter from William Bar on
her Twitter account and this is just
amazing because most of the reporting on
this letter that we're showing you is
about when will the report ultimately be
released and bar lists a whole bunch of
different things that need to be
retracted things that are classified all
these categories of things named by
William Bar that need to be retracted
but if you look closely at the bottom of
the first page you will see William bar
say my March 24 letter bar now
specifically calling it it's just it's
just a letter that's all it is not a
summary not a report it's just a letter
my March 24 letter was not and did not
purport to be an exhaustive recounting
of the special counsels investigation or
report as my letter made clear my
notification to Congress and the
public provided pending the release of
the report a summary of its principal
conclusions that is what he considers to
be the bottom line and he goes on to say
quote I do not believe it would be in
the public's interest for me to attempt
to summarize the full report or to
release it in cereal or piecemeal
fashion that's right we know that and
now he's saying it and he's right the
document does not call itself a summary
per se it's a list of what William bar
says are the most relevant conclusions
but despite William bar now saying this
seven days after he released this thing
trumpets and corporate media and
right-wing media and even some left-wing
media claimed utter and complete
exoneration on the basis of this letter
being a summary of the entire report
this the transparency of this four-page
letter as a political document is very
very clear this is a walk back but a
calculated one bar never actually says
everything that's in the report is here
what he said is the important things
from the report are in this letter that
is used for a week by the 24-hour news
cycle to claim that this is it this is
vindication this means there's no
evidence of obstruction this this is a
total clear vindication of Donald Trump
and everybody around him and then
William Bar says listen that was just
what I thought it was the principal
conclusions that was never actually
meant to be a summary but the cat is out
of the bag the the horses have left the
stable so to speak here and what we now
recognize as effectively a press release
from William bar a week in a day ago of
four pages was merely a pretext for
Donald Trump and his cronies to claim
exoneration and this is you know the
thing about it Pat it worked I mean
they're not stupid okay a Trump picked
Barr specifically to manage the release
of this of this report Barr did exactly
what he was supposed to do which is put
out a political document that is a
pretext for Sean Hannity and Jeanine
Pirro and Trump and from jr. and
everybody to say it's over folks no
collusion T Sh
and hats and whatever else and now we
actually have to try to walk back the
misunderstandings which they
deliberately calculated and planned
congratulations to them I mean they did
it right I think William bara
successfully primed the pump on this and
you have to wonder why did we even need
his summary to begin with like I
understand he wanted to put out the
initial conclusions and he wanted to
make sure that we had some understanding
of what went on with the Miller report
because it was a matter of public
interest and also if the president was
indeed compromised by Russia we'd want
to know that as soon as possible but we
waited a year and a half two years for
this investigation to end I think we
could wait a few more weeks to actually
see their mother report his itself we
don't need William bars summary consider
for a second if Democrats didn't control
the House of Representatives right now
we might never get the truth I mean we
still might not but by the way we don't
know ultimately what it is that we're
going to get hopefully we will get it
but if Democrats didn't control the
house there is no chance that we're
getting it and key point as I said this
is not a document summarizing the probe
it's a press release PR friendly
cheerleading document meant specifically
to serve as the pretext for Trump to
claim victory go around the country
claiming victory which he did and it
worked on lots of Americans a lot of the
individuals are pretty dim-witted that
are involved here but the big picture of
this scam was executed very very well
and I guess in some sense I mean it's
it's disgusting but I've got to give him
credit they actually pulled it off let
me know what you think I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show one of today's David
Pakman show sponsors is simple habit an
app that provides a massive library of
really excellent five-minute guided
meditations they're letting everybody in
our audience use it completely free for
one week when you go to simple habit
comm slash Pakman we've talked a lot on
the program about the growing scientific
evidence pointing to the benefits of
meditation and what really sets simple
habit apart is the variety of guided
meditations that they offer more than
2,000 made for many different issues
that you may be dealing with if you need
help falling asleep if you have anxiety
that you're dealing with if you want to
be more productive during the day they
have meditations specifically tailored
for certain times of day like when
you're waking up or your commute to work
or when you've just gotten home from
work I'm a huge advocate of meditation
myself I've really enjoyed integrating
simple habit into my day and each
meditation takes just five minutes and
they're very easy to follow maybe you
want to feel more grounded before you
start your day at work or at school
maybe you want to keep your mind a
little more clear so that it's easier to
accomplish your goals or you just want a
calmer more peaceful experience
throughout your day simple habit can
help you get there it just won the 2018
Google Play award for best well-being
app it's available on Android iOS and
web browser and you can try it
completely free for a week check it out
go to simple habit comm slash Pakman
I've put a link down below underneath
the video